okay let's try our next caller from the
three one two area code
caller from three one two who's this hi
my name is Charlotte hurry Davis hi how
are you good good can you hear me all
right yeah we can hear you all right I
requested about the farm bill mostly
your opinion two-parter short-term
question is what everybody asks what do
you think's gonna happen with snap the
second part of the question is a little
more what you think for the future
because I'm stymied by this one and I'm
a dietician so I think about at all time
oh man I'm sorry to interrupt Charlotte
I'm not understanding yeah what was the
first question
let's turn Charlotte up as much as
possible what can you just repeat the
first question for me yeah can you hear
me better off speaker oh yeah please
never speaker I mean speaker is the last
if you ever call into any show never use
speakerphone please speakerphone is
ruining the radio Colin well then lesson
learned
all right the first are the questions
what do you think it's gonna happen with
snap you're talking about because
obvious right yeah yeah but the part of
the farm bill that people actually
discuss on the news you know regularly
yeah or more so than anything else I
think there are attempts made to cut
food stamps but I believe that in the
end most Republicans and Democrats will
probably make a deal to keep them well I
wonder about that because it's a good
way it's a good thing to push if you're
trying to promote your love of the
middle class while you're you know
cutting money elsewhere but often it you
know usually it's thrown out at the end
of the day and doesn't get improved at
all so I hear you there and I agree too
second part I'm really interested in
your and your thoughts about this so we
have dietary recommendations right and I
know Pat's probably listening rate that
push that we should is not only cleaner
and healthier food to whatever extent
you know the kind of Institute a mess
and slogans get said through corporate
media and pushed back at us so eat less
sugar right
but we don't really subsidize the
production rate less than 1% of our
subsidies currently go to quote-unquote
specialty crops which are fruits and
vegetables to those of us you know who
aren't eating exclusively grains and soy
for a living or meat or dairy for living
so do you see any top forward through
either through either party I'm pretty
stumped on this to actually make the
plate recommendation matched up more
appropriately with what we're actually
trying to grow and subsidize you know
all other conversations about the
quality of that production being
completely satisfied just know I don't I
don't see that happening because you're
suggesting that not look yeah I don't
think so you think it's gonna happen cuz
you're suggesting that we look at
dietary recommendations and then decide
on what should be subsidized based on
that but it's heck kind of happening the
opposite way in the United States we've
decided for example that we subsidize
corn even though there's no big call for
everybody to eat more and more corn
products particularly not high fructose
corn syrup so I don't see that happening
in either party unfortunately Charlotte
I do appreciate that although do you
have to move on in fact let's take a
quick break and then we will come back
and continue on the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50